En este video hablaremos del área total de
la superficie de una pirámide. Pero antes,
recordemos qué es una pirámide y qué elementos
la componen. Una pirámide es un poliedro, donde
una de sus caras es una región poligonal llamada
base y las otras caras son regiones triangulares
con un vértice en común. Los elementos de la
pirámide son seis: primero tenemos esta parte,
que se llama base -que podemos ver aquí-;
por acá tenemos las caras laterales que,
como sabemos, deben de ser triangulares; estas
son las aristas, puedes verlas; después tenemos
los vértices de nuestra pirámide, al vértice de
arriba de nuestra pirámide se le llama ápice;
por acá se muestra la altura de la pirámide, es
decir, la distancia que va del ápice al centro
de la base de la pirámide. Y, ahora, un concepto
nuevo: apotema o altura de las caras laterales,
que es esta de aquí. El apotema es la distancia
que hay del ápice al punto medio de uno de los
lados de la base, dicho de otra manera: es
la altura del triángulo que forma cada cara
lateral. El objetivo y la pregunta interesante
de este video es: ¿cómo encontramos el área
total de la superficie de una pirámide?
Bueno, para visualizar mejor el área total
de cualquier pirámide vamos a descomponerla
en figuras planas. Observa: en este caso,
se trata de una pirámide cuadrangular, entonces
tenemos una base, que es un cuadrado, y después
tenemos cuatro triángulos isósceles iguales: 1,
2, 3, 4. De nuevo, aquí podemos ver las aristas,
o los lados de la base, y aquí se puede ver con
mayor claridad el apotema de la pirámide, que
es lo mismo que la altura de estos triángulos. Así
que para encontrar el área total de esta pirámide,
necesitamos encontrar, primero, el área de
la base, que llamaremos A subíndice b, y
al área de la base le sumaremos el área de cada
una de las caras de estos triángulos laterales,
que sombrearemos con este color rosado y que
llamaremos A subíndice l, es decir: A subíndice
l es el área de uno de estos triángulos isósceles.
Como en una pirámide cuadrangular tenemos cuatro,
entonces vamos a sumar cuatro veces A subíndice
l, o, dicho de otra manera, vamos a multiplicar
A subíndice l por cuatro. Es muy importante
que no olvidemos multiplicar el área lateral,
es decir, el área de la sección triangular,
por la cantidad de lados de nuestra base, que,
en este caso, es 4. Pon mucha atención a esto.
Ahora, para entender mejor cómo podemos calcular
el área total de una pirámide, hagamos un ejemplo
de la vida real. Veamos el siguiente escenario:
imagina que queremos limpiar los vidrios de la
pirámide invertida del Museo Louvre. Debo aclarar
que se trata de una pirámide común y corriente,
sólo que la pusieron de cabeza. Sería muy buena
idea saber cuántos metros cuadrados tiene el área
de la superficie para calcular el tiempo que nos
tomará hacerlo. Si sabemos que la base cuadrada
tiene 16 metros por lado y la altura de la
pirámide es de 7 metros, ¿cómo podemos encontrar
el área total de la superficie de la pirámide para
saber cuánto tiempo nos llevará? Bien, pausa
el video e intenta encontrar la respuesta con
la ayuda de la fórmula del área de la superficie
de una pirámide. Este problema me agrada mucho.
Lo grandioso es que tenemos las medidas reales
de la segunda pirámide francesa más importante;
la primera es la pirámide principal del Louvre,
aunque ésta es mi favorita. Como dato interesante,
esta pirámide fue construida por el arquitecto
chino Ming Pei, en 1989, y pesa 180 toneladas.
¡Una belleza! Muy bien, trabajemos juntos. Vamos a
escribir por aquí las medidas de nuestra pirámide,
y queremos encontrar el área total de la
superficie de la pirámide con esta expresión,
así que primero encontremos el área de la base
de nuestra pirámide. Para eso sólo habrá que
multiplicar el lado por el lado, ¿cierto? El área
de un cuadrado se calcula como: lado por lado,
o lado al cuadrado, que es 16 metros, todo esto
al cuadrado y, bueno, 16 por 16, o 16 al cuadrado,
es 256 metros cuadrados; así que el área de la
base son 256 metros cuadrados. Ahora bien, tenemos
que sumar a esta área de la base las cuatro áreas
laterales, por lo tanto, requerimos encontrar el
área de los triángulos laterales de esta pirámide.
Una vez que encontremos el área de un triángulo
lateral, al multiplicarlo por 4, ya tendremos
una pirámide cuadrangular y estaremos muy cerca
del resultado. ¿Cómo podemos encontrar el área
lateral? Bueno, tal vez estés tentado a decir:
"Sabemos que el área de un triángulo se obtiene
multiplicando la base por la altura entre 2; como
tenemos un triángulo, hay que multiplicar la base
del triángulo que, ya sabemos que mide lo mismo
que el lado de la base de la pirámide, por la
altura de la pirámide y dividirla entre 2"; pero
ten cuidado, esta idea no es del todo correcta. En
efecto, sabemos que el área de un triángulo es su
base por su altura entre 2, también sabemos que
la base del triángulo es, en efecto, lo que mide
uno de los lados del cuadrado que forma la base
de la pirámide, es decir, 16 metros; sin embargo,
el dato que nos dan es la altura de la pirámide,
no la altura del triángulo lateral. Recuerda que
a la altura del triángulo lateral le llamamos
apotema de la pirámide. Nuestra expresión para
encontrar el área lateral es, bueno, base por
el apotema de la pirámide entre 2, entonces,
¿cómo podemos encontrar el apotema de la pirámide
si tenemos la altura de la pirámide? Bueno:
utilizando el Teorema de Pitágoras. Podemos ver
que se forma un triángulo rectángulo entre la
altura de la pirámide, la mitad de lo que mide
uno de los lados de la base de la pirámide y el
apotema de la pirámide. Esto pasará siempre en
una pirámide regular. Y nosotros tenemos como
datos los dos catetos: sabemos que la altura de
la pirámide es de 7 metros y la mitad del lado
de la base de la pirámide es de 16 metros entre
2, es decir, 8 metros. Entonces utilicemos el
Teorema de Pitágoras para obtener el apotema
de la pirámide. Sabemos que el primer cateto
al cuadrado, es decir 8 metros -todo esto al
cuadrado-, más el segundo cateto al cuadrado,
es decir, 7 metros -esto también al cuadrado-,
debe de ser igual al apotema de la pirámide al
cuadrado. Entonces tenemos que: 8 metros, todo
eso al cuadrado, más 7 metros, esto al cuadrado,
eso es lo mismo que 64 metros cuadrados más 49
metros cuadrados, y eso es lo mismo que el apotema
al cuadrado, y 64 metros cuadrados más 49 metros
cuadrados es 113 metros cuadrados. Si sacamos raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados de la ecuación, tenemos
que el apotema de la pirámide es 10.63 metros,
redondeando al centésimo más cercano, así
que vamos a escribirlo: 10.63 metros -por
aquí también: 10.63 metros-. Perfecto. Esto es
muy emocionante. Ya estamos muy cerca del final,
porque en nuestra fórmula tenemos que: el área
lateral es igual a la base por el apotema de
la pirámide entre 2, y sabemos que la base del
triángulo es de 16 metros, y acabamos de encontrar
que el apotema es de 10.63 metros. Entonces,
ya podemos calcular nuestra área lateral,
será: 16 metros • 10.63 metros / 2; y esto es
lo mismo que, si sacamos nuestra calculadora:
tenemos que 16 • 10.63 / 2, esto es lo mismo que
85.04 metros cuadrados. Muy bien, ya tenemos el
área lateral de una de las secciones triangulares.
Pero en esta pirámide tenemos cuatro de ellas,
ya que tenemos una pirámide cuadrangular, así
que para encontrar el área total que buscamos
tenemos que sumar el área de la base más cuatro
veces esta área lateral; entonces el área total
va a ser igual a: el área de la base, pero el área
de la base son 256 metros cuadrados, más 4 veces
el área lateral, que son 85.04 metros cuadrados.
Entonces, de nuevo, saquemos nuestra calculadora,
y tenemos que: 256 + 4 • 85.04, esto es lo
mismo que 596.16 metros cuadrados. Y ya está,
hemos acabado. Ya que el área total cubierta
por el vidrio de la pirámide es de 596.16
metros cuadrados. Por lo pronto, ya conocemos
el área que tenemos que limpiar -y creo que
nos va a llevar mucho tiempo-, por lo tanto,
eso es todo por este video. Hasta la próxima.